and the blue jays are going to lean on
their ace this afternoon on gin ryu
will get the start uh sparkling numbers
all the way around in his eight starts
this year won his fourth game
the last time out that was against
boston seven very good innings seven
strikeouts
so with that velocity there's a liner
back into left pretty well tagged and
that's gonna be off the wall
hits the screening and takes a sharp
angle toward the
foul line and into second a double
for a rosarina
[Applause]
bouncing ball espana makes a nice play
as he backed up
now he throws high and he came down
glad he came down before diaz crossed
the bag according to junior valentine
the first base impact
big slow curveball meadows strikes out
and well mark go
but goes the right fielder on on one of
rosarina leads margot swings and lines
one
over the leaping bushet out of the left
center for a base hit
a rose arena helmet flying a rounding
third and he will score and margot just
as he did yesterday
gives the raise the lead it is one to
nothing
well they got picked off marco guessed
wrong with ryu
and now they have been a run down and he
is doing a good job of staying alive and
boba shed will finally put the tag on
him
right-hander michael walka coming off
the il had the hamstring tightness is
making his fifth start of the season
seventh overall appearance
he drives this one toward right center
laying out for it is brett
phillips who makes the catch phillips
racing to his left
and he got horizontal there for a moment
with that extended glove
arm and made the catch
[Applause]
ground ball toward the middle and raise
had him defense
perfectly getting 333
and he sends this one deep into center
field
phillips is right there on the track for
this one to retire the side
up and away brussels strikes out second
strike out of the ball game in the early
glory
for the first time you will see hunjin
ryu
face off against g-man choi in an
all-korean battle
ground ball simeon will get a nice hop
about chest high
so the first matchup goes in ryu's favor
[Applause]
there's a fly ball to rydrich is under
it and he makes the catch
a two out single is stranded on the base
[Applause]
and the fastball up is skied to deep
center
phillips is going to have room on the
track making the catch
a couple steps left before he found the
wall out there
hit last night one for four
sends this one into center field and
phillips stays busy
well he's handled the four of the five
put outs here
and that one got him a swing and miss is
that pitch
and turn him into very good big leaguers
in tampa
phillips strikes out on a 3-2 pitch
third strikeout for ryu first time
through the order
one and two off the end of the back five
ball to grichik
there's a lot of turnover but it works
diaz gets jammed has plenty of time and
he throws them up
first pitch on its way to danny jansen
is sliced right to the first baseman
g mon choi one pitch one out
[Applause]
of the chop two third across and a nice
pick by choi
on the throw from diaz
there's a good pitch down and away as
meadow strikes out for a second time
against so here is the g-man sure
yunjin ryu match-up again
right there and that ball is going to be
off the wall davis plays it perfectly
they're waving the runner around third
they got a shot at him at home here's
the trophy
and they got him what a terrific play by
davis and mo michelle
jonathan played it perfectly he was
shaded in that direction
as here's the oscar hernandez
i am deep and this one is gone
hernandez looked like he got a little
bit jammed on that thing
and he hit it out of the ballpark and
then off the bus side and left field his
sixth home run of the season and with
one swing of the map day oscar has tied
it up yeah
owning one of five hits given up by ryu
that's a shot into left field that's got
some carry
and we'll get out of here an 0-2 pitch
and mejia
lines one out to left that's his third
home run of the year
and the rays will take a two to one lead
got to get the hands close to the body
to get the barrel to the baseball and
boy did he ever
back to back two out singles now set the
table for t
oscar he drops this one into center
that's going to score [ __ ]
phillips will not make a throw as bo
comes in and how about
three consecutive two out singles and
we're tied once again
and as soon kwan from [ __ ] told me this
is the match-up
i've been waiting for my entire life
strike three carry who paints the
outside
quarter yanjin ryu watching here in the
seventh inning
up the middle bow ranging to his left
and a good stretch over it first by
vladi once again
drops down a bun ryu will go to first
and makes a good play
engine ryu two runs eight hits over six
and two thirds
one on and one out and here is randall
gretchek
hits this one to center phillips is back
this ball is up and gone
randall bridgette it's a home run to
straight away
center field his eighth of the season
and the blue jays score two here in the
eighth to take a 4-2 lead
remember the rays are trying to extend a
nine-game
winning streak nice play by vladi second
for one
no throw to first what a play by
guerrero nifty grabbed by guerrero
and he hits the runner at second
the rays have choi at third trying run
at first is walls here is phillips
phillips a ground ball base head into
center field
joy will score it's a one run ball game
bases loaded two outs and austin meadows
will be the hitter
here's another 3-2 pitch and a tie ball
game
he walks him forcing home walls
the third walk of the inning now they're
loaded with manuel margot coming up
and there is ball four the reigns are
going to take the lead
so bergen has walked meadows and margot
and it's 5-4 raids brasso comes up but
the base is still loaded 3-0 pitch
and ball four brasso draws the walk and
another run is
home
see some changes in the outfield with
that's phillips out there and left and
he's
tracking that one down in front of the
wall nice to be able to come out of that
smiling
and bobashette will step in so this game
is not over yet
and a swing and a miss on the fastball
rays win this one and what a victory it
is
to extend the winning streak to 10.
they score four times in the ninth
inning
and defeat the toronto blue jays 6-4